selon cette vidéo vérifier par le new
york times ce ne serait pas un mais bien
deux missiles qui aurait abattu l'avion
à bord duquel se trouvaient les 57
canadien après le premier impact on voit
un second missile se dirigeait en
direction de l'appareil pour finalement
le percuter une deuxième fois
environ 23 secondes après le premier
impact des révélations troublantes qui
jette un nouvel éclairage sur l'anc est
d'ailleurs une première photo montre
deux enquêteurs canadiens en iran
le cliché a été publié par les autorités
iraniennes
les enquêteurs canadiens auraient eu
accès au site grâce aux pressions
exercées par l'ukraine
le premier ministre trudeau a
personnellement remercié le président
ukrainien l'ukraine pro mais également
d'aider le canada pour faciliter le
rapatriement des dépouilles des victimes
canadiennes le difficile travail
d'identification des corps se poursuit
une lourde tâche à laquelle participent
des agents de la grc au vert à joliet
dans un discours télévisé le président
hassan rohani promet de punir tous les
responsables du drame
si l'iran annoncé des arrestations on ne
sait pas combien de personne ni qui a
été arrêté à la lumière de cette
tragédie l'ancien premier ministre
stephen harper a publiquement critiqué
l'iran soutient qu'un changement de
régime en iran est nécessaire si on
souhaite la paix au moyen orient
ici vincent maisonneuve radio canada
montréal